before we bring Reese on III think he's
already done an interview with the show
during the commercial break Fritzi was I
mean fritzy was just talking his ear off
fritzy asked him like five questions
before he was very excited it's he's
kind enough to come on he's breaking all
kinds of records I mean one of the
greatest starts in the history of Major
League Baseball to someone's career and
next thing I know I'm asking him eleven
questions and left you with pretty much
nothing to ask me well let's bring him
on then Reese oskins Phillies outfield
one of the hottest hitters in baseball
right now added being a part of a triple
play to his resume on Sunday and Reese
kind enough to join me here on the show
Reese did you think you were doing the
interview while you were being
interviewed by Fritzi
yes I didn't know that but you know it's
always good to get a little warm up
before you go on the show well
congratulations on the the star let me
ask you first about the triple play did
you think you would caught the ball yeah
yeah I didn't I thought I got a glove
first and I didn't hear you know a
bounce of the ball while the play was
going on so I was just hoping that you
know they have the right angle for the
replay to UM be able to tell that the
ball did hit the ground what's the rule
on the transition do you have to take
the ball out of the glove or once you
get catch it that's it yeah I'm not sure
what the exact rule is but I think you
know once they ruled it it to catch I
think I had kind of adjusted the ball in
the glove before I got to my feet I was
hoping that you know that was enough for
them to be able to tell that pea was the
catch and the ball is dropped on the
transfer we think he'd double play there
I was I looked up and I saw that Rizzo
was standing on third-base and not even
really realizing where the runner was
that was on first so you know I I saw
Cesar Hernandez saying on second base so
I try to get the ball to him as quickly
and calmly as possible and then realized
that the runner on first base was kind
of caught in between so and there was a
triple boy you've been part of a triple
play before no and of course you know
the first one that I've seen live or
I've been a part of is me coming or is
me playing left field instead of you
know the first base that I'm accustomed
to so they sold a weird game
takatori sonken's Philly's out for the
joining me here on the Dan Patrick show
I want to get to your start Rhys but the
early stages of your your call up there
you couldn't get a hit first well but
bats no hits when you're going through
that type of earth I wouldn't call it a
slump but early seasons early struggles
what are you thinking I can't wait to
get the first one you know out of the
way and so we can kind of just relax in
the box and and and play the game you
know I think the first one is always
hardest to get and obviously that was
proven to me on a pretty big stage you
got the 11 home runs in your first 18
games when you got called up what do you
hope would be the result what kind of
numbers did you hope to put up yeah I
don't know there were necessarily
numbers you know I come into the lineup
where I think my main goal was to be
some sort of run producer you know Pete
Pete has put me right in the middle of
the lineup and that's what those guys
dog is is to produce runs and driving
runs you know when you're doing
opportunity so I was just trying to soak
up as much information as I can you know
in the time that I was going to be up
here and learn a lot while I'm up here
and you know establish some sort of
foundation hopefully for for next year
you know when you bring a young guy up
there's not a lot of tape on him you're
obviously a power hitter in the minor
leagues but our pitchers throwing you
the ball I mean are you hitting balls
that you like yeah yeah you know for the
most part the balls that I've you know
been able to drive I've been mistakes
but that's you know what you have to do
in baseball especially at this level you
know these guys are too good where if
you miss the mistakes you're probably
out especially with the pitchers you
know and today in today's game a lot of
velocity a lot of lot of good breaking
balls so you can't afford to miss the
mistakes that they make and you know
there's just been a little bit of a
stretch where I haven't missed that much
are you seeing pitchers start to adjust
you yeah you know I think that happens
daily from game to game and and I even
comment back to about and
you know that's the beauty about this
game is it is a general adjustments and
I think you know the little chess match
that you have with between the pitcher
and the catcher each pitch of every
about is something why I think this this
game is so awesome I know you grew up in
the Bay Area watched a lot of Barry
Bonds you ever catch a bonds homerun
ball I didn't but man I wish I had you
know I remember watching every at-bat
that I could you know stopping homework
stopping dinner whatever I was doing to
run into the TV to watch his at-bat so
you know fun to watch is history that
that was unfolding before my eyes and I
was lucky enough to be able to be a fan
of it you ever get on the boat in
McCovey Cove and wait for him I I did
not what I have been out there as a fan
and it's a it's a pretty cool atmosphere
you know we were pretty lucky in
Northern California to have the run that
they had from 2010 to 2014 so it was you
know pretty electric in San Francisco if
you had been out there in a ball landed
in the cove would you have jumped in
after it no doubt no doubt would have
been freezing man it would have been
worth it we're watching Giancarlo
Stanton put up some monster home run
numbers this year as a chance to eclipse
60 maybe get above that that Roger Maris
mark of 61 is the guy that grew up
watching bonds and clearly aware of
everything baseball's gone on has gone
on a baseball the last two decades
do you consider bonds the homerun King
yeah listen
obviously you know the whole story
is an issue a thing it's it's there it's
always going to be there but in my eyes
you still have to be able to have the
talent to hit the ball you know I think
the most amazing thing about bonds was
that he would get one pitch to hit a
game maybe a series and he would be
locked in enough to be able to put you
know his best swing on it and most the
time the ball would you know went out of
the ballpark so to me that was the most
amazing thing yeah plus nobody ever
threw to him like ever
right exactly I mean the whole season
where he had over 200 losses
that's incredible I love the the on pace
numbers 11 home runs in 18 games do you
know how many home runs you're on pace
to have no I do not I think it's yeah
I'm guessing it's like over a hundred
right if you if it's over 162 games
seasons got to be over 100 yeah I guess
it's right around 100 yeah you have a
goal if you played the full season how
many home runs Dickey can hit at the
major-league level that's a great
question you know I'm hoping that you
know in my in my career I've been
anywhere from about about 22 to 35 so
anywhere in that range is something that
is you know I guess a goal that I all
set for myself but as long as I'm
driving in runs you know I think the
hundred RBI mark is something that I
would be very proud of if I was able to
get to that in my career
he's them no one ever no one ever got in
trouble for leading the league in
doubles either so is the pitching
significantly different and what you saw
in the minor leagues yeah the thing
about the pitching is I think that guys
are are more likely to try to you know
get yourself let you get yourself out
there hasn't been a lot of pitches in
the middle of the plate and I think
hitters get in trouble when you start
swinging at pitches that are outside of
the strike zone so you know pictures
know that this stuff is better and the
velocity is up and you know coupled with
the fact that they're willing to let you
get yourself out I think that has been
the biggest job erase congratulations on
the hot start great start with the
Phillies and on the triple play the yet
on Sunday best of luck the rest of the
season and thanks for joining me here on
the show yeah Chris thank you man I
appreciate you having me that's resource
concealing outfielder joining me here on
the Dan Patrick show the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience